electro gol del pino sin su icónico
sombrero el presidente de perú pedro
castillo tomó la juramentación a su
nuevo consejo de ministros el cuarto en
seis meses incluyó cambios en seis
sectores además de la presidencia del
consejo de ministros que ahora estará
bajo el mando de aníbal torres jurar por
dios y estos santos evangelios
desempeñar leal y fielmente el cargo de
presidente del consejo de ministros que
os confío sí juro
si así lo hiciera es que dios os premio
y si no él y la patria os lo demanda
ángel y the phone solo reemplazará en el
cargo de ministro de justicia hernán
condori es el nuevo ministro de salud
castillo retiró a wilber supo del
ministerio del ambiente ya que era uno
de los ministros más cuestionados del
gabinete y designó a modesto montoya en
este consejo ministerial sólo hay tres
mujeres una menos que en el anterior y
dos menos que en el de mirtha vásquez
entre ellas la activista feminista diana
miloslavich stupak quien se pronunció
previo a la ceremonia
demandamos un gobierno que nos
represente y que nos incluya en las
políticas de estado para alcanzar la
igualdad de género y no la
discriminación en el ejercicio de
nuestros derechos
ahora torres tiene 30 días para
solicitar el voto de confianza al
congreso de la república el nombramiento
de este nuevo gabinete se da tras la
renuncia de héctor valer a la
presidencia del consejo de ministros
quien fue presionado por la indignación
del pueblo peruano tras conocer las
acusaciones de violencia doméstica que
pesan sobre el duró tres días en el
cargo